oh my gosh like best zoom ever
hi little mix how are you queens
hi
the kids how are you
i'm so good i'm so excited that your
greatest hits album between us is coming
out jade did you ever expect that you
would make it to this point of releasing
a greatest hits album
i mean
i'm not sure to be honest i know that
we're iconic and so we deserve this
moment
did i think we'd fully get here i'm not
sure but you know only the legends get
to see they've got enough bots to create
the greatest hits out of
mm-hmm
yes and there are so many bops that are
on this album between us also features
five new tracks i have to say love sweet
love
self love anthem it is a bop do you each
have a favorite new song from between us
oh
i think mine would probably be
between us
um just because it's like jade keeps
describing it as a love song to each
other and i absolutely love that um
it's just about our friendship and about
our sisterhood
and yeah it's just a really beautiful
song yeah what about you leanne
um i think i'm at the second perry we're
between us but i also love love sweet
love that is probably one of my faves it
just makes me feel good
it's a feel good song
and jade how about yourself
sorry i'm just finding better light
that's okay
yeah i think obviously that one i mean
sorry that one
oh oh my god
um yeah i think
uh between us yeah because of what the
girls said but i do also love love sweet
love i think the vocals are amazing
and
yeah it's a good moment
they are all such bops perry the
sentiment surrounding uh the track cut
you off is that you all found it really
therapeutic to work on that can you
describe the process and what the song
means to you
yeah well basically
me and the girls decided to have therapy
together um because we thought it would
be like huge because you know we were
going through a lot at the time we were
very finding things really difficult so
we do individual therapy but we thought
doing it as a group would be nice to
kind of have each other to cry on and
have each other to like
vent like in the same room with somebody
who
doesn't necessarily know us so like
having a therapist with us was just like
really healthy i think
and
she basically taught us that the
negative people in our lives you have to
imagine like
the negative people and then you imagine
like a rope tied to them and you're
connected in this weird way in this
mentality that we have
and you have to cut them off and you
have to just imagine these big ass
scissors cut them off and that's it try
and distance yourself from negative
horrible people and jade went to the
studio and she was like guys that like
seemed like such a sick concept to me so
i've wrote a song about it
and i just think it's amazing so i do
think we should cut out the negative
people in our lives i'm just saying so
that's what this song is about
you were absolutely right in my own life
i've had to do that and it did take me
to a different place it really does make
a difference when you cut out that
negative energy in your life and
recognize it all six of your albums have
had you know such a cohesive theme of
female empowerment and like owning the
power that you have leanne why do you
think it's so important to include that
message within your music
wow
um well i feel like little mix we have
always set out to
want to inspire people we've always
wanted to inspire and i think we've done
that through our music i mean we have
such a massive platform what what would
we be who would be if we didn't use that
like we we want to use it to
to inspire people so
yeah i think
it's just it's super important for us to
put that into our music
yeah yeah definitely it is super
important because so many people listen
to what you're saying and take that into
their own lives and that's really
powerful as musicians and artists to be
able to give that power to people i also
want to congratulate you leanne and
perry on your new little bundles of joy
congratulations
have you offered up uh babysitting yet
have you changed any dirty diapers for
either of them yet or will you be no
no no
no no i would do though like when we get
on when we get on the road and we're on
tour whenever the girls need help i will
definitely do that i do have a bit of
experience i've got two nieces and a
nephew
so you know i have i have been there
helping out so i'm more than happy to be
the best auntie there is
that is that is the right answer but no
dirty diapers for now no dirty diapers
for now
listen throughout your career there have
always constantly been rumors about
breakups and these types of things and
even still now today that happens
i think personally the music that you
are releasing now is the strongest
little mix has ever been and i'm not
just saying that like i really do think
that but you know perry why do you think
the press is so fascinated with pitting
powerful women against each other and
always constantly making up these rumors
of breakups because they don't do that
to male groups
yeah you know i don't know i think just
the industry in general is harder than
women and i think that you're they find
it really hard to
they can't fathom why girls would be in
a group together work together for 10
years live in each other's pockets and
actually adore each other so people have
always
made up their own kind of
like silly stories about us
not liking each other us falling out
with each other um
but
truth be told we're literally obsessed
with each other like little mix will
never
not be little mixed like yes we might
venture out and do our own things we
might start doing our own sort of music
movies like leanne's just been in the
masters movie and we might start
venturing out with fashion but no matter
what happens individually we'll always
just support each other and support each
other's own ventures but little mix will
never die little mixes forever
little mixes for life
you know listen
your mixers always have your back the
support that you get online
is mind-blowing to me because your fans
are so dedicated to this group
but there are a lot of trolls online i
see it myself i deal with it myself so
leanne how do you brush off that
negativity and what advice would you
give to someone in a similar situation
because it can be
damaging in a lot of ways to read
negativity about yourselves
yeah um i mean i'm not gonna sit here
and say that it's not hard because
it is and you could read ten nice
comments on one negative and that one
would stand out but
i feel like the best bit of advice i was
given recently was
if you
say if you have a book in front of your
face what do you see
you see the book take the book away and
just look around you and look what look
what's amazing around you and
look how much you have to be thankful
for like and if you think like it's the
same with the internet put your phone
down and it's not there anymore you know
like
i i just think best thing to do is is to
not look at it
because
it's literally
the smallest
fragment of your life like the internet
is actually quite a small thing if you
think about it
like it's a small community
so
yeah
yeah no you're absolutely right i saw
something online uh a woman was wearing
a jacket maybe you saw it on twitter and
on the back it said your opinion does
not cut me a check and i'm like
that is absolutely right
yeah
yeah yes
it's not what rupaul says lester paying
your bills pay those [ __ ] in your
mind
that is absolutely right you're 100
right
oh sorry no i was just going to say oh
like
with age like i've just turned 30 and
i'm just like
it really
it doesn't it's so irrelevant it really
is
like i've just had children like that's
my focus you know
a hundred percent yeah we've been saying
it all day like
that for me has just put everything into
perspective like my children like that
is what matters
100
way back when jade when you opened for
ariana grande in toronto
uh you were surprised that the audience
here in canada knew all the words and
all the lyrics to the song so i do have
to ask um canada loves you are you gonna
be coming on tour anytime soon in north
america or canada because like i want to
be their front row
i know that we'd love to we absolutely
love canada the fans are amazing it's
obviously such such a beautiful country
um
yeah i remember we had the best we had
the best time there um actually i love
hannah does drag race as well that's
very good
brooklyn is one of my favorite queens
so you know canada's really rapping
um and yeah we would love we would love
to come back
i remember how beautiful
yes
i went traveling around canada with my
dad and we rented this massive rv
and we just went all over canada and it
was the most incredible experience of my
life it was unreal
it's just beautiful
it's a beautiful country jade you
mentioned canada's drag race there and
i'm gonna do a shameless plug for myself
i just had a drag show
release it's in the it's in the uk as
well it's called call me mother
peppermint is a star on it there's a
bunch of people i'm hosting the show so
it is in the uk so if you love canada's
drivers
oh my god yes i've been taught about
this numerous times i'm gonna watch it
of course i'm gonna watch it i love it i
love it so much listen you recently made
history as the only girl group to spend
100 weeks in the top 10 of the official
singles chart in the uk
that is absolutely incredible jade when
you hear stats like that what does that
mean to you like when you actually break
it down and realize that you are making
history
oh i mean
it's just
psychotic what can i say
no we really are doing the damn thing
i'm sorry but 10 years is
you know we're i feel like we've reached
the point now where we can say
yes we are incredible and we're allowed
to blow smoke up our own asses because
we've earned it
so here's the match
line it up baby
i love it so much as you enter this
between us air finally perry what do you
hope fans feel or think of reflecting on
the last 10 years of little mix
i think just what a ride we've had i
think it's been the most incredible 10
years of our lives and i hope that the
fans feel the same and i think like
obviously the fans who started out
loving us back in the day have grown
with us we've all grown as women i feel
like our fans have grown with us and
it's just been an incredible journey and
i think this album is just a look back
on everything in all of our successes
and just
basically everything that we love to do
so yeah
it's a celebration
celebrate baby and like i said little
mix has never been stronger the music
itself is
you know the best it's ever been i'm not
saying the old music isn't great because
i love to bop to that but this is a new
era and i am in love with it so
congratulations on the new music and the
greatest hits album it's been a complete
pleasure to talk to all three of you and
hopefully we'll catch up in canada again
soon
yes yeah thank you so much thank you so
much
thank you